although Dune 2 has been officially
pushed back to next year due to the
strikes director Dennis milnev has
expressed his enthusiasm for a third
installment the initial idea was to
adapt the famous novel by Frank Herbert
into two films part two was supposed to
be the end of the story but there's
still room for more fans of the original
know of course that the film adaptations
are merely adaptations of the first
novel however the literary work of
arrakis includes several other books
that also provide material for potential
future film adaptations this opinion is
likewise shared by Dennis villenev who
talked about a possible third part in an
interview with Empire it is to be based
on the second novel Dune Messiah it
shows that Paul is anything but a hero
even if many perceive him that way